>>> AN IRANIAN JOURNALIST AND
ACTIVIST SAYS SHE IS BEING
TARGETED ONCE AGAIN AFTER
OFFICIALS ARRESTED A MAN NEAR
HER BROOKLYN HOME.
OFFICIALS FOUND A SUITCASE WITH
AN AK-47 ASSAULT RIFLE AND
SECOND MAGAZINE WHILE SEARCHING
THE SUSPECT'S CAR LAST WEEK.
JOURNALIST MASIH ALINEJAD JOINS
US NOW.
SHE'S BEEN CRITICAL OF THE
ISLAMIC REPUBLIC AND ALSO
TARGETED IN AN ALLEGED
KIDNAPPING PLOT LAST YEAR
SEPARATELY.
THE INDICTMENT IN THIS CASE IS
ALLEGING THE PLOT -- OR IN THAT
CASE, ALLEGES THE PLOT WAS
ORGANIZED BY AN IRANIAN
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIAL, BUT
IRAN'S MINISTRY OF FOREIGN
AFFAIRS DENIED ANY INVOLVEMENT,
CALLING THE ACCUSATION BASELESS
AND RIDICULOUS.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH SO MUCH.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING AFTER THIS
HAPPENED?
>> TO BE HONEST, LAST YEAR WHEN
I WAS HERE, IT WAS A TIME WHEN
THE FBI THOUGHT THEY STOPPED THE
KIDNAPPING PLOT.
I THOUGHT, OKAY, I'M SAFE.
FINALLY I'M GOING TO ENJOY MY
FREEDOM IN AMERICA TO GIVE VOICE
TO VOICELESS PEOPLE INSIDE IRAN.
NOW I'VE BEEN TOLD A FEW DAYS
AGO THAT I HAVE TO MOVE FROM MY
HOUSE BECAUSE THIS TIME A MAN
WAS IN FRONT OF MY HOUSE WITH
LOADED GUNS TO KILL ME.
AND I WAS LIKE SHOCKED.
IT'S NOT ABOUT ME.
MY STEPCHILDREN LIVE IN THE SAME
HOUSE.
JUST IMAGINE IF THE GUY HAD OPEN
FIRE, WHO KNOWS HOW MANY OF MY
NEIGHBORS WOULD HAVE BEEN
KILLED, MY BEAUTIFUL AND
SUPPORTIVE NEIGHBORS.
SO, FOR ME, IT WAS SHOCKING.
I KEEP WATCHING HIS VIDEO AND
HIS FACE.
I'M NOT SCARED OF MY LIFE AT ALL
BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT I'M DOING.
I HAVE ONLY ONE LIFE AND I
DEDICATED MY LIFE TO GIVE VOICE
TO IRANIAN PEOPLE INSIDE IRAN
WHO DAILY GO TO THE STREET, FACE
GUNS AND BULLETS TO PROTEST
AGAINST IRANIAN REGIME.
BUT THIS IS HAPPENING IN
AMERICA.
THIS IS HAPPENING SECOND TIME.
THEY TRIED TO ASSASSINATE, TO
KILL AND KIDNAP AMERICAN CITIZEN
ON U.S. SOIL.
SO, I'M NOT SCARED OF MY LIFE
BUT THIS IS SCARY HAPPENING IN
FRONT OF THE EYES OF THE WHOLE
WORLD, ESPECIALLY THE U.S.
ADMINISTRATION.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION WHEN
YOU FIRST BECAME AWARE OF THIS
STRANGER OUTSIDE YOUR HOME WITH
A GUN?
>> THE MOMENT THAT THE GUY CAME
TO MY HOUSE, I WAS ON A ZOOM
MEETING.
VERY IMPORTANT MEETING.
HOW THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT, THE
DICTATORS FROM IRAN AND
VENEZUELA GET UNITED, HOW WE CAN
BE UNITED.
SO, I WAS FOCUSED ON MY WORK.
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT.
WHEN I LEARNED FROM THE FBI THAT
HE WAS THERE, I KEPT WATCHING
THE IMAGE.
I WAS LIKE, WOW.
IN HERE, IN FRONT OF MY HOUSE IN
BROOKLYN?
AND I SAW THE GUN AND I WAS
LIKE, MY GOD, THIS IS THE GUN
BEING USED BY RUSSIAN AGAINST
UKRAINIAN.
NOW IT'S DURING THE WAR, THIS
GUN BEING USED MANY TIMES, NOW
BEING USED IN BROOKLYN IN FRONT
OF MY HOUSE?
I DON'T HAVE ANY WEAPON.
MY WEAPON IS -- MY WEAPON IS MY
MOBILE.
AND I HAVE LIKE FOLLOWERS ON MY
INSTAGRAM AND MY SOCIAL MEDIA.
I PUBLISH VIDEOS OF IRANIAN
MOTHERS WHO IRANIAN KILLED THEIR
BOYS.
I WANT TO USE YOUR PLATFORM
BECAUSE YOU NEVER SEE THESE
WOMEN.
THIS BRAVE WOMAN PROTESTED
AGAINST FORCED HIJAB.
THEY FORCED HIJAB LAST WEEK.
SHE DENOUNCED HERSELF ON TV.
SHE DENOUNCED ME ONLY LAST WEEK.
FOUR WOMEN PROTESTED AGAINST
FORCED HIJAB.
I PUBLISHED THEIR VIDEO.
THEIR VIDEO WENT VIRAL, BEING
WATCHED MILLIONS OF TIMES.
THE GOVERNMENT TOOK THEM,
IRANIAN NATIONAL TELEVISION,
FO
FORCED HIJAB.
IT'S NOT ABOUT ME.
IT'S ABOUT BRAVE IRANIAN WOMEN.
ALL I DO IS GIVE THEM VOICE.
THIS PERPETRATOR, HE'S A
RESIDENT OF NEW YORK, WALKED
RIGHT UP TO A VIDEO CAMERA ON --
NEAR YOUR FRONT DOOR.
DOESN'T SEEM PARTICULARLY SMART
TO DO THAT.
WHY DO YOU SEE THAT HE IS LINKED
TO THIS FORMER PLOT?
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS WORKING OUT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK POLICE ARE
GOING TO FIND?
>> THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
LOOK, I HAVE ONLY ONE ENEMY.
THE FIRST THEY PUT MY BROTHER IN
JAIL TO PUNISH ME.
SECOND, THEY BROUGHT MY SISTER
ON TV TO DISOWN ME PUBLICLY.
THIRD, THEY INTERROGATED MY
MOTHER FOR HOURS AND HOURS AND
ASK HER TO TAKE ME TO TURKEY.
IF IT WAS NOT MY BROTHER
EXPOSING THIS, I WOULD GO THERE
AND HUG MY MOM BECAUSE I MISS MY
FAMILY.
SO, AND THEN THEY ARRESTED ALL
THESE WOMEN AND BROUGHT THEM ON
TV TO DISOWN ME PUBLICLY.
WHAT IT SHOWS TO YOU, I DON'T
HAVE ANY ENEMY.
I'M NOT A CRIMINAL.
SO, OF COURSE, THIS IS THE
IRANIAN REGIME.
WHEN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT DO NOT
TAKE A STRONG ACTION, OF COURSE,
THEY FEEL MORE POWERFUL TO
CONTINUE THIS.
I SEE THE PATTERN, THE
CONTINUATION OF OPPRESSING
WOMEN, OPPRESSING DISSIDENTS
OUTSIDE IRAN.
>> IT'S CLEAR THAT YOUR VOICE IS
A THREAT TO THE OOK RACY.
>> MY VOICE IS MORE POWERFUL
THAN A WEAPON.
>> MY QUESTION TO YOU, AS YOU
LOOK AT CURRENT EVENTS UNFOLD,
YOU LOOK AT THE NEW ALLIANCE,
APPARENTLY, BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
IRAN, YOU LOOK AT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TRYING TO GET
DEMOCRACIES TO STAND UP TO
AUTOCRACIES.
WHAT DO THE ALLIANCES REPRESENT?
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
ALL THESE DICTATORS, THEY LEARN
FROM EACH OTHER.
IT'S LIKE THEY HAVE A BOOK AND
THEY FOLLOW ALL THE RULES.
THEY ASSASSINATE PEOPLE.
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT, VENEZUELAN
GOVERNMENT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT JUST ME.
IF THE U.S. GOVERNMENT, THE
EUROPEAN DO NOT GET UNITED AS
MUCH AS THE DICTATORS ARE
UNITED, WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
SAFE.
EVEN YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
I'M AN AMERICAN CITIZEN.
I WAS PRACTICING MY FREEDOM OF
SPEECH.
I LEFT IRAN TO BE SAFE HERE IN
AMERICA.
IT HAS BEEN ONE YEAR I MOVED
FROM DIFFERENT SAFE HOUSES.
I DESERVE TO HAVE A NORMAL LIFE.
THE DICTATORS ARE HELPING EACH
OTHER, BUT THE DEMOCRATIC
COUNTRIES KNOW, MY DEMAND, AND
I'M BEING VERY HONEST, IT'S
CLEARLY THAT THE IRANIAN REGIME
IS WATCHING ME.
THEY'RE READING MY WORDS.
THEY ARE FOLLOWING ME.
I HAVE ONLY ONE MESSAGE FOR
THEM.
CAN I USE YOUR CAMERA AND TALK
TO THEM?
>> PLEASE.
>> WHICH CAMERA?
I KNOW THEY'RE LISTENING TO ME.
>> THIS ONE.
>> I WANT TO TELL YOU --
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
GO TO HELL.
I AM NOT SCARED OF YOU.
I HAVE ONLY ONE LIFE.
YOU CARE ABOUT POWER.
I CARE ABOUT MY DIGNITY AND
FREEDOM.
LIKE MILLIONS OF OTHER PEOPLE
INSIDE IRAN.
I'M NOT SCARED OF YOU.
YOU CAN KILL ME, BUT YOU CANNOT
KILL THE IDEA, THE IDEA IS JUST
FIGHTING FOR FREEDOM, DIGNITY.
HERE I HAVE A MESSAGE FOR BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
SHUT DOWN THE INTERSECTION.
THROW OUT ALL THE IRANIAN
DIPLOMATS.
WHY ARE THEY HERE?
THE IRANIAN REGIME CHALLENGED
U.S. ON U.S. SOIL.
I DESERVE TO HAVE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
KICK THEM OUT.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME, THEY
ARE GOING TO COME AFTER MORE